yes it's local news where each guest has
to share a story from wherever they're
from and then I vote on a winner and
that person gets
we interrupt Gutfeld for this breaking
news serial Streaker and disgraced
newsman Chet van Jansen has been
stripped of all his George Clooney
look-alike contest wins this afternoon
video was released of Van jansen's
streaking last night at a minor league
baseball game once van Jansen was
apprehended cops say he claimed that
he's been doing all this to impress none
other than actor Wayne Brady and it
appears it might have worked earlier
today van Jansen and Brady were spotted
enjoying a leisurely stroll together on
the beach in Malibu and all this comes
after Brady came out this week as
pansexual a fascinating development to
say the least we'll keep you updated on
this story as we learn more now back to
Gutfeld
[Music]
I'm happy for Jeff and Wayne may they
have a great future together Doug let's
go first with your local story is it
from Jolly Old England it is it is and
it's because nothing happens does it
involve a chimney sweep oh no no no it's
even less exciting oh okay this involves
a very important story that's happening
there's a Charming seaside resort called
Blackpool but there's a zoo there and uh
it has a pelican and the Pelican has
just flown off and it turns out this is
come as a complete surprise to the zoo
staff the Pelican has flown off because
of Seagulls apparently there are
hundreds and hundreds of Seagulls in the
area and so there's a missing Pelican on
the loose in Blackpool but that's not
the main part of the story that I'm
interested in the main part is this I
hope you get to it
locals have been asked to scare off the
seagulls ah and volunteer to come to the
zoo and spend the day dressed as birds
and this nice lady
this nice lady is one of the 200
volunteers wow and you could say she's a
lovely bird she's a little isn't that
what you say in English
yes I think the seagulls are coming back
just to have another laugh at the humans
but anyways that's a fun story at first
I wasn't so hard on it but now I like it
people in costume Tyrus make me laugh
and laugh I do
your turn
someone give me some clown makeup so I
can beat him up
in Miles stomping grounds Boston
Massachusetts a trucker decided to
retire he told his boss that's it I'm
done I'm out the game and he went and
got a scratch off ticket and won a
million dollars what what a way to go
out retirement wise he literally driving
up and down the United States bringing
everybody their goods and whatnot and
he's a tiny person
well you don't have to be big to hold a
check Greg so that's what I mean look
how it look at chat he must be like a
three inches are you hoping you're
taller than him is that what this is
about like
just be happy that one of your guys won
like that was a tall brother who won him
and I'm still happy for his little white
self the government's gonna take uh half
of it though right he's still got half
more than he did at the end of the day
when he retired Greg that is true and
it's a tiny person that money will go a
long way
because it's a little guy in a big check
Tudor what what you yeah go ahead this
is a special Michigan story and it's
Michigan both ways because Home Depot is
going to bring back hot dogs at this
store called Frank's again in Detroit
and I did this specially for Mitt Romney
because he is originally from Michigan I
don't know if you heard recently he his
favorite meat it's a hot dog the hot dog
which is like a lot of different Meats
together right but he said he likes them
in buns and out of buns and Frank's
again wants you to know that the best
part of their hot dog is the steamed bun
come to Detroit and get the steamed buns
that's what I'm gonna have for dinner
tonight I think I'm gonna have a hot dog
I'm gonna eat it favorite meat I thought
he was going to say steam buns I really
did
yeah that's what they called me in high
school
but then I quit Dancing
so cat
but how's it going what's new we're
doing a segment it's called local news
what's your story oh I'm so glad you
asked
mine is from Sandusky Ohio there is an
amusement park there called Cedar Point
that I've been to so many times have you
yes so many times I always wanted to go
and I've never been invited it's well an
invitation I mean no you just need money
um and you go but these people got stuck
on one of the roller coasters and they
were stuck there but they had to walk
down a staircase oh I would not like
that I know oh God Biden doing that
you know yeah I mean no I can't but I
hope that they leveraged it a little bit
because like the worst part of an
amusement park is like you're waiting in
line and like you're waiting and all the
teens are there touching each other oh I
hate that you but if you're like hey you
maybe walk down a staircase can I go
first yeah that would be excellent
exactly
well that was a great story thank you
you know what you know what I did my
best wow they'll remember that for the
rest of their lives unless they're
brutally murdered
up next okay I said the brutal murder
will be worse they'll remember that
they'll remember that but only briefly
because they'll be dead up next he says
he's no funny duddy cause he's attracted
to everybody wait hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else